Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Thor 4 love and
thunder video big surprise just a couple
days after I posted a Thor 4 video Taika
Waititi who did a big livestream and
revealed a whole bunch of details he
revealed some script pages that featured
Iron Man coming back is crazy so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions for Thor 4 on the video all
just go down the list here there's a lot
of things that he revealed a bunch of
Easter eggs and it confirms a bunch of
details that we had wondered about
before especially Christian Bale's
character in what's going on during the
events of Thor 4 with the Thor character
and because Hulk was such a big
character during Thor Ragnarok he also
addressed Hulk crossing over into Thor 4
starting with number 10 the Asgardians
living in new Asgard in Norway will try
and blend in more with the other humans
on earth similar to what we saw them all
doing during Avengers end game new
Asgard had become a fishing town with
them working the sea and culturally
they'll also start to try and fit in
more with other human customs and
behavior best example of that during
avengers endgame was when Korg was
wearing that Hawaiian shirt playing
fortnight complaining about new master
like he was just another gamer bro
chilling out between Giants space
adventures more to that too 9
Meek's new body so during the livestream
tyka drops some teaser concept art for
Thor 4 as you can see it features meek
getting a couple new exoskeleton bodies
allowing him to walk around without
having to be carried by Korg all the
time and it seems like they're even
having him walk around wearing human
clothes on top of the exoskeleton in
order to seem more human this is some
straight-up men and black stuff with
aliens walking around trying to pass as
human it's not clear if he be walking
around looking like this in another
human city on earth or if this would be
happening with him walking around new
Asgard tyka also said that we would
learn more about Korg's backstories so
it sounds like Korg is going to continue to
be a big character during the movie -
this is also just meant to be some a
concept art of what new Asgard looks
like during the events of Thor 4 so you
can see it's been built out a lot more
they have ships here on the side they
look a little more traditional Asgardian
in their design but obviously they're
very advanced culture so you see a lot
of their designs integrated with more
earth-based designs
eight he talked about the crossover with
the guardians of the galaxy in Thor four
and Guardians three he said this
Avengers endgame ending scene with Thor
boarding the guardianship proclaiming
them the as guardians of the galaxy was
only him tagging along briefly just
clarifying that the guardians will cameo
at the beginning of Thor 4 love and
thunder and vice versa
how Thor will cameo during guardians of
the galaxy three when that movie comes
around based on the schedule of movies
that Marvel just released with all the
dates that they've delayed it sounds
like guardians of the galaxy three won't
come out till at least 2022 so for those
who are wondering what's going to happen to
Thor after Thor 4 love and thunder
since it's implied the guardians of the
galaxy three takes place after the
events of Thor four I think we can take
that to mean the Thor does not die
during Thor four if there was any
question about that that would totally
suck so everybody be happy about more
Thor after Thor four we still have the
promise of Thor in Avengers five Sunday
Secret Wars Thor vs. Silver Surfer at
some point but more big crossovers 7 he
also talked about beta ray bill so taiga
clarified that he was excited he loved
the beta ray bill character and wants to
include him in the movie but he says
that there on the fourth draft of the
script right now and just for reference
the scripts for these big movies not
just Marvel movies all big blockbusters
like this they're never completely done
they'll continue reworking the script
all through the filming process changing
dialogue changing whole scenes right up
until the last minute so he did caution
that a lot of stuff is up in the air
with Thor 4 because of what's
happening with the virus and all the
delays right now just implying that we
shouldn't assume that beta ray bill is
going to be a really huge character during
Thor 4 but they did canonize him during
Thor Ragnarok so he does exist in the
MCU even if we haven't seen him walking
around on screen yet 6 this is actually
a pretty big one he confirmed that
they're not going to do fad Thor during
Thor 4 so for those of you that hated
the thick version of Thor the comedy bro
version of Thor I think that's what
Marvel is calling him bro Thor his words
were something like he hasn't figured
out exactly how he's going to introduce the
newer swole version of Thor who's all
buff and lost that beer weight but he
feels like he's done the fad Thor thing
and the gag is played out already a lot
of people just wondered what Thor was
going to look like at the beginning of
Thor 4 what he
still be the fat version of Thor is he
going to go back to being super buff this
also tracks with what Chris Hemsworth
has been doing for the last month or so
if you've been watching his social media
post he's been posting videos of him
getting super ripped inside this house
with his trainers doing all kinds of
improvised workouts during the lockdown
number 5 everybody wondering is Loki
coming back Tyga's words exactly our I
can't say which basically means yes Loki
is coming back it'd be the newer version
of Loki from Avengers and game who
escaped with the tesseract same version
of Loki that's going to be showing up on
the Disney Plus series time traveling
and dealing with the time variance
Authority and that takes place before
the events of Thor 4 so it sounds like
he'll get a bunch of character
development so he'll be a little bit
different than he was during Avengers
end game it would be weird to do a Thor
movie without a version of Loki so I
think we all kind of assumed that he
would show up in some way number 4
addressing the Thor 4 script pages
featuring Iron Man that showed up during
the livestream I got so many messages
about this on my Instagram and my
Twitter people wondering what's going on
why did he leaked these script pages so
we'll just read from the script pages
here this is actually pretty funny so
Thor sees someone appear before him and
says doth my eyes deceive me the smoke
clears and standing before him Thor says
Tony in its Iron Man Tony says was up
I'm alive perfectly normal perfectly
Tony Thor says you're back then Iron Man
says I'm back baby and gives Thor a hug
Thor says but how I saw you die Iron Man
says science also Thanos is back
Thor asks if his mother Frigga has come
back and this says are we assembling
again Iron Man says again again it's go
time
then Iron Man pushes a button on his
stark watch and within seconds is lit up
again Iron Man is back only this time
the suit is covered in decals all the
flags of every nation on earth Iron Man
says everyone who died is coming back
and this time were avenging even more
than ever from now on we'll be known as
there's a beat and he says the Avengers
then the Scriptures ends with fur Tony
for Earth for Asgard so obviously that
is the most ridiculous script page with
Iron Man coming back ever it should be
clear that is just a joke obviously Iron
Man isn't going to  come back to life for
Thor 4
there have been reports about Iron Man
coming back during Marvel phase four
just not how people expected like there
been reports that Iron Man shows up
during the Black Widow movie but they're
actually using deleted scenes from
Captain America's Civil War in new
context because it takes place between
the events of Captain America Civil War
and Avengers infinity war last year
Robert Downey jr. also went on a couple
press tours talking about his future as
Iron Man in Marvel's future and how he's
going to be watching it all play out
he's not completely ruling out coming
back at all but that doesn't mean that
he's going to be rushing back right away
three real stuff though tyka did confirm
Christian Bale was in the movie he is
the main villain but that he was not
playing Silver Surfer
and Silver Surfer will not be featured
in the movie at all they're not going to do
Marvel's Point Break even though that
would be a cool movie I guess some
people have just been asking tyka a lot
on social whether or not the movie would
feature a Silver Surfer cameo because
they can use all those characters now
the Fox x-men the Fantastic Four
characters anytime they want whatever
Marvel's plans for Silver Surfer are
he's not going to cameo during Thor 4-2
he confirmed that they were going to do
the star sharks from the gore the god
butchers storyline in the comics those
are the space sharks that you see Thor
fighting here that take place while he's
also in the middle of this Gore the god
butcher adventure seemingly confirming
that they might actually be doing
Christian Bale Gore the god butcher
everyone just kind of wondering who he's
playing he didn't say exactly who
Christian Bale's villain character was
only an intergalactic villain and it
just sounds like Gore the god butcher is
the next level up for Thor in terms of
challenges he also said that Thor four
is meant to be way crazier than Thor
Ragnarok so the story will be way bigger
way more epic and way weirder in the
best possible way when you think about
weird Thor stuff just remember all the
weird stuff they did during Ragnarok and
imagine that times 10 in 1 when Mark
Ruffalo joined him on the livestream he
revealed that Hulk might come back for
Thor 4 two but I think a lot of that
just depends on scheduling just to be
clear though Mark Ruffalo still has more
Marvel movies on his original Marvel
contract I did a video a little while
ago about this but he did a special
Comic Con panel just a couple months ago
talking about the future of his Hulk in
the MCU he said he was pitching Kevin
Feige on ideas for a new Hulk movie he
said he would love to do Hulk vs
Wolverine in the movies at some point he
said he's been pitching a brand-new
Incredible Hulk TV series for Disney
Plus in addition to the she-hulk series
and that he would also cross over onto
the she-hulk Disney Plus series but they
were still kind of figuring out how that
series was going to work and practically
how he would crossover and what that
would look like so there's still a lot
of stuff happening behind the scenes
with the Disney Plus series right now
but I think it would be really cool to
see an Incredible Hulk TV series and if
it wasn't clear the reason why Disney
can do that on Disney Plus but they
can't do a hoax solo movie is because
marble still has the TV rights to do the
hook completely it's just the movie
distribution rights that Universal holds
so that's why the movies are such a
problem for the Hulk but the TV shows
are not in that part of his ideas for
future versions of the Hulk would deal
more with the banner versus Hulk of it
all such that they skipped over during
Avengers endgame overall I'm really
surprised by all the stuff that tyka
revealed but everyone just let me know
in the comments what you're most excited
about based on all the reveals that tyka
has made and if you have any big
questions about what's going on with the
movie I just did a video about cosmic
Thor during Thor 4 about him leveling
up into the most powerful version that
he's ever been in before because that's
kind of the dragonball methodology of
Thor movies he gets his ass kicked
finds new power new strength within
himself and becomes even more powerful
by the end of the movie
congratulations black Zell you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
Rune King Thor in the movies would be
amazing
everyone click here for my new Thor 4
teaser video for a cosmic Thor and click
here for that deleted scene of Thor
getting the odinforce and becoming even
more powerful thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe I'll see
you guys tonight!